[Music]
i've been reading the news because
they're all covering this debate
and they're all talking about a tactic
that most presidential debaters use
that's called pivoting
i didn't know the term either it's
called pivoting but it's when a
candidate is asked a question on a
specific topic topic that they don't
want to talk about and they deliberately
change their answer to a different topic
for example if they're asked about the
economy they quickly switch the topic to
health care all right well i think this
is terrible i think these politicians
are evading the real questions and that
can't be good for our democracy i think
it's bad for the whole system don't you
agree andy
uh well yeah sure uh that pivoting thing
is interesting but i'd actually like to
talk to you right now about something a
little closer to home
sure what is it
i brought a big pastrami sandwich into
work today
i put it in my dressing room fridge and
when i went to get it it was gone
and i wonder if you knew anything about
that
i'm really glad you asked me that
question andy
you may have a missing sandwich but you
know what's also missing
proper funding for our nation's schools
our teachers and students deserve better
and if we want to stay competitive in
the global marketplace we need to take
education a top priority do we not
ladies and gentlemen
conan just admit you took my sandwich
all day you've been stinking of pastrami
well you're right andy and i'll tell you
what else stinks
the unhealthy alliance between
corporations and electoral process we
need to stop the influx of corporate
donations in our political process and
stop it now
okay i didn't want to do this but i have
surveillance footage from my dressing
room allen roll that tape please
hmm
andy sandwich
gotcha now how do you explain that it's
all there in black and white
yes andy it is all there in black and
white
but maybe it's time to stop looking at
things as black or white
we're not black or white we are black
and white like me and my good friend mr
dion cole
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you very much
thanks for sharing that sandwich with me
shut up about the sandwich we'll take a
break we'll be right back